*packing noises*
MARK: Hey, Bob!
Bob, have you seen my charger?
(Silence)
MARK: Bob...?
(More silence)
(creepy music starts)
(creepy music intensifies)
(jumpscare, loud creepy music)
DELTA: (jumble of voices, all incomprehensible)
MARK: No, no! I just wanna go home!
(Mark whimpers)
DELTA: *deep voice* Come over here,  *incomprehensible*
(DELTA laughs, sound of belt hitting Mark)
MARK: Hi!
I'm Mark, also known as Markiplier.
I hope none of your neighbors hear this,
'cause I'm practically shouting my name
and everyone's gonna come bursting to the door.
BOB: (in the background) It's fiiine.
MARK: It's PROBABLY fine
But I am not home!
I'm still in Bob's apartment!
He's fucking sick of me! Right, Bob?
(camera turns to Bob, who gives a thumbs up. )
MARK: He's really peeved that he has to keep coming
to the airport to pick me up.
But I can't help it, because DELTA keeps canceling my flights over and over again!
So I've been stuck in D.C. for 2 more days, and I'm still gonna be sleeping over here
One more night and then leaving early in the
morning to go back to Los Angeles.
SO, tomorrow, I don't have videos for it... but as soon
as I get back, I'm gonna play No Man's Sky,
but until then, I'M STUCK HERE doing NOTHING!
Yaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaay.
Well, I mean, I guess not doing nothing, we've been hangin' out.
It's been fun. Lil' bit.. You can't see
but he's nodding his head.
Definitely agreeing with me about how fun it's been!
Ah, this is bullshit, let me start over, this is all bullshit.
HI! I'm Mark, welcome back! You didn't go anywhere-
FUCK! God damn it... (Bob laughing in the background)
Hi! My name is Markiplier! I am...
... a YouTuber?
So, I'm gonna be back in L.A. very soon,
it's just not here YET.
I did not PLAN to be here 2 extra days,
so obviously I didn't record videos for 2 EXTRA DAYS-
and also, I'm missing No Man's Sky, which is a REALLY COOL GAME!
I watched Bob play it- as soon as I get back I'm gonna be doing videos on it.
And, uh, it'll be super cool- and there's be a whole bunch of other videos that are going to be underway.
But I can't DO THAT because I'm here! In this LOVELY APARTMENT.
It's a shithole.
I guess that's all I had to say then, so...
BOB: (in the background) I think that was the end of it MARK: (laughs) that's the end though-
BOB: (in the background) What can you do?
MARK: What can you do?
Alright alright, SO yeah, I'll be back when I can.
Thank you everybody for being patient
Uh, thank you for everybody who made #freemarkiplier trend on Twitter for a brief period of time
while I was in the Airport.
Uh... but, yeah, I'll be- I'll be back- soon, it'll be great.
I promise. Maybe.
Unless it gets canceled again. 'Cause holy shit.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Byeee.
Ow, I'll assemble something outta that clusterfuck.
BOB: Also, to be clear, he's not being an ass, it's not that he's calling this apartment that I live in a shithole,
MARK: (laughing) You have to clarify?
BOB: I /also/ think it's a shithole!
*Mark still laughing* BOB: Well... you said it- I was like there's gonna be people who are like.
"Holy fuck, Mark. I know your flight got canceled, but why??"
It's, I think it's a shithole too.
This is like, a temporary apartment.
We leave in 3 days. SO
Fuck this apartment.
MARK: Yeah.
BOB: Not Mark.
Everyone but Mark. MARK: Yeah...
MARK: So, I'm NOT AN ASSHOLE. Get it?
I'm just a victim.